culturally in the view of Time magazine
it was the greatest show of the entire
20th century financially is credited
with saving an entire television network
undoubtedly it's the biggest cartoon
series on the planet so what exactly has
happened to make such a TV Titan turn
yellow in the face of some confection
controversy if you're still confused
about which show this is well is a brief
clue got it
yes it's the everyday story of crazy
anarchic yellow folk living in
Springfield USA who were members friends
neighbors work colleagues or others who
know the Simpsons
well Hindu shopkeeper ARPU could
reportedly be sidelined following
complaints his character is an overtly
racist misrepresentation of South Asians
in truth I've only ever laughed with
ARPU rather than at him this after all
is the guy who was so brainy he knew
more than his examiner when he applied
for his US citizenship
every Simpsons character is a caricature
not every blue-collar Middle American is
as work-shy as Homer not every neighbor
is as pious or nosy as Flanders it's a
gag goodness gracious me when like this
end first of all can I say I'm a huge
fan of The Simpsons and when it started
3000 years ago whatever it is up who was
a great character then times have
changed
I'm sorry in the same way there was a
time where we would love for Alf garnet
we wouldn't watch that now mm-hmm we've
moved on do not agree were laughing with
him I don't laugh at him I know it's a
bit of a caricature and I think The
Simpsons has such clever writers they
could create a better character that
wasn't offensive in that way the times
have moved on and we are it feels
sometimes Nick's women against the tide
with this stuff I mean at the end of the
day it seems like this is the momentum
forgive the pun but the world is headed
in that direction however I think
would have been a clever alternative a
middle path between what is speculated
as scrapping the character of course he
hasn't officially announced to scrap he
did appear with a halo over his head and
of course suggests that they're gonna
write into the script he's dead
but between scrapping the character and
keeping them as it is I think there is a
sensible way middle ground in a moment
June I want us to have a look at I'll
prove him sexual hey you're a boo not
happy but paddle on aren't you you're
like the guy you're a legend around here
- is it true you once worked 96 hours
straight yes it was horrible like dillio
by the end I thought that was a
hummingbird of some kind oh yeah you
know I studied your all security tapes
oh it's so bad but the worst thing is
this Hank Azaria who does the voice for
Abu they don't even have a South Asian
actually doing the vu let's get the
middle ground the middle ground is
simple you you because unlike the
comedian what's-his-name that you refer
to only because I know the comedian that
you say we don't listen to anymore
because these jokes well I've got it
that's I'm sorry cuz he I was known for
racist jokes wasn't like immediate
unlike him it was a character this this
guy is in a living script which of the
rioters could change and adapt so they
could have kept the character not saying
you know scrapped him but I could have
kept him adapted him hired an Indian
actor for his voice and adapted his role
you don't have to have an Indian guy
doing an Indian voice it's called
there's not offensive the show
specifically because it was politically
incorrect that's why you can't combat
stereotypes in a show where every
character is a stereotype you know every
culture has the stereotype and Apple was
it was a comment let me know it was a
comment on the stereotype but I think
that the serious point here is that now
no writer is gonna write a part for
non-white person unless that person is
going to be portrayed in it as a hundred
percent positive and and and the penalty
of that is positive nuance and the
problem with that is creators will then
play it safe and art in all forms or
something because yeah I'm just take
here's someone making the opposite point
comedy has changed a lot in the
intervening nearly 30 years so while in
1990 when there's a dearth of South
Asian comedy writers or actors you know
this idea of Hank Azaria a white guy
giving the voice to a boo yeah it's kind
of funny but nearly 30 years later the
writing feels a bit lazy bit stereotyped
and it has had some negative real-world
effects on South Asian people so if
there's been many times I've left a pub
or you know been walking down the street
and someone's done that up who voice
just yelling it at me I mean that's a
shocker but what is interesting is that
tastes change in taste changes over time
it was interesting in your introduction
that you said the Simpsons was was seen
by time as the greatest cultural show of
the 20th century that was the 20th
century yeah and the thing is changed do
I send what science and watch something
the other day which showed Kenny Lynch
no remember Ken yes Kenny Lynch was it
no you can't Kenny Lynch was a black
comedian who didn't mind people being
rude about him being black and there's
this amazing clip I saw the other day of
of Kenny Lynch chasing a woman off the
stage and her coming back with two black
handprints on her boobs and these things
that made people laugh 20 years this is
a courtroom the Hoover Institution
stands at the Stanford University she
said let's accept that app whose accent
is inauthentic doesn't matter he's a
caricature like everyone else in the
show most notably Homer Simpson
exaggeratedly feckless underemployed
blue collar white guy who goes as cheap
beer at midday he's coastal America's
archetype of a trump voter although he
first appears 3-1 years ago and that's
the [ __ ] supposed to laugh at hysteria
you see people don't laugh at things
like the BBC still runs dad's army yes a
weekend's almost in a prime time people
still laugh would you not let me just
read this in our harem sir because I
think Charles Moore writing in The
Telegraph says that we this is actually
a celebration this is a celebration of
immigration our poo is a highly
intelligent man he came top of his class
of 7 million at Caltech the Technical
University of Calcutta he's a member of
Mensa he holds a PhD in computer science
he's loyal to his Hindu culture but very
proud to be American he's hard wale
hardworking and unfailingly polite now I
just bring in a clip from the
documentary the trouble with our poo and
I think everything you've just said that
it's funny because it's racist
there's a food count as a minstrel since
it's brown paint a white guy's voice
vacations remember please children that
in life there is nothing that is not so
disgusting that it cannot be sold on a
heated roller at a nearly criminal
markup now I realized some of you think
I'm some annoying PC social justice
warrior that's very sensitive and you're
probably thinking come on snowflake let
it go well I have let it go for 28 years
had you gone on Twitter you've seen lots
of South Asians they got the jokes they
love losing my job let's turn to the
resident Salvation let's see what the
public think please all right so the
public don't agree that Apple's
character in The Simpsons is racist 74%
say that he it wasn't racist 10% think
it wasn't 16% don't know and again I'm
just gonna appeal guys it's a cartoon
I'm just gonna appeal to everyone's
common sense there is a way for without
as I say repeat there isn't we don't
have to scrap characters like this we
can adapt them and can still keep the
stereotypical elements if we want but
you know I just think that Gregg's point
was really powerful that actually I
don't want him scrapped and I didn't
ever complain but I do agree that stuff
that seemed funny back then we watch the
ground in sand use this stuff in there
which is jokes being made at Asian
Americans expenses that today we just
don't we were find funny but he wouldn't
run the German sketch in the 40 is 40
towers now when the Germans come to stay
at the hotel is that excised forever
because they're white because they're
now it is Elsa says it's also all the
time and you can play stuff over time
and I think there's some stuff you say
he's that I mean all that's happening
here I suspect is that the people who
are responsible for the show are
beginning to say isn't this getting a
bit tired he you know he is a good robot
he's got his own business
he's the ladies love um he's got a
muscle car he's done reading five hours
a day still support eight children and
now
Lefty's will put him out of work dude
and just to add to your point about
forty towers the difference is Fawlty
Towers we'd be watching a clip from 30
years ago we wouldn't be making that
same clip now and that's the point with
our people he's a bring him into the
twenty fifteen children are called
Lincoln freedom Conda Lisa coke pepsi
manifest destiny apple pie and Superman
those names aren't playing on a
stereotype this is genuinely funny right
yeah they were playing on a stereotype
they'd be doing things like up whose
surname which can you pronounce it seems
none of us can pronounce our purser name
and thank goodness we don't have to try
coming up after the break why I think
Meghan is giving the Royals a modern
makeover
[Music]